hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a Japanese mystery thriller
film called Death Note spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the opening scene takes place in Tokyo
where the police are in pursuit of a
fugitive named yusuke hibisawa in an
attempt to evade capture yusuke takes an
innocent girl as a hostage and threatens
her life however he suddenly experiences
severe chest pain and collapses
resulting in his death elsewhere the
deputy director of Foreign Affairs walks
out of his office only to find himself
surrounded by the media the reporters
start flooding him with several
allegations and questions but before he
can respond he collapses and dies just
like yusuke in similar ways a sequence
of unexplained deaths takes place in the
city all of which involve criminals as
the frequency of these deaths increases
certain religious groups interpret them
as the divine retribution of God against
Sinners meanwhile the public is divided
regarding the cause of these deaths with
many believing that an individual known
as Kira is responsible some support his
actions While others view him as nothing
more than a criminal one evening a
breaking news bullet captures the
attention of the crowd the reporter
announces that a man named hiromichi
imizumi has broken into a financial
company and is currently holding
individuals hostage amidst the throng of
people there is a man named Light Yagami
who upon hearing the news takes out his
notebook and writes hiromichi's name in
it moments later the reporter shockingly
announces that hiromichi has died some
of the hostages claimed that he
collapsed After experiencing sudden
chest pain all these criminals have to
stop eating McDonald's following this
the movie Cuts back to a few weeks
earlier light hacks into the Japanese
Police website and learns that all cases
of wanted criminals are being closed to
confirm his suspicions he goes to a
local bar where he overhears one of the
criminals admitting that the police have
released him and no one can incarcerate
him now hearing this light becomes
distraught and he starts losing faith in
the nation's legal system one rainy
night he comes across a mysterious
looking notebook named death note and
and takes it with him upon reaching home
he reads the first page which states
that whoever's name is written in the
notebook will die as expected light
doesn't take it seriously and assumes it
to be a joke he then turns on the TV and
sees the news of a murderer who's been
causing Havoc as of late for the fun of
it light nonchalantly Scribbles the
murderer's name on The Notebook the next
morning while having breakfast he reads
the newspaper and gets shocked to learn
about the murderer sudden and
inexplicable death but despite this
light remains skeptical and believes it
to be a mere coincidence later on as he
is strolling down the street he comes
across the same criminal he had seen in
the local bar before in order to verify
his assumptions light writes the
criminal's name in The Death Note while
observing him from the opposite side of
the road much to his surprise the
criminal immediately experiences chest
pain and dies this finally convinces
light of the notebook's extraordinary
capabilities and he proceeds to read all
of its rules carefully according to its
rules the notebook Works only if the
writer can visualize the purse person's
face in their mind additionally if the
cause of death is not specified within
40 seconds of writing the person's name
they will die of McDonald's that night
light is walking back home when he
encounters the god of death who
introduces himself as ryuk it is
revealed that only those who touch the
Death Note can see him initially light
is terrified to see the scary figure and
asks if he has come for the book but
ryuk promises that he means no harm he
then explains that light can use the
book as many times as he wants to
hearing this our protagonist becomes
determined to create a world without
crime where the righteous will be
celebrated and the Wicked Will cower in
fear yes says ryuk
at the present time the police are still
investigating the mysterious deaths that
have been occurring but so far they have
no leads on the so-called law Lord Kira
hence they turn to a mysterious figure
known only as L for help L communicates
with the cops via a laptop and suspects
that Kira is from Japan and is
committing crimes on his own so he comes
up with a plan L with permission from
the police uses a fugitive criminal to
challenge Kira through a live broadcast
the plan works and when light watches
the broadcast he becomes enraged at the
criminal's insulting words hence he
quickly writes down his name in The
Death Note causing the criminal to die
instantly following this incident the
real voice of L appears on the live
broadcast and he explains that the whole
thing was a trap set to narrow down Kira
he reveals that the conference was
broadcast exclusively in Japan and now
the police know Kira is from Japan L
also warns that once Kira is apprehended
he will be sentenced to death meanwhile
light who is watching from home becomes
terrified of the threats however he is
powerless to intervene because Al never
shows his face to anyone in the next
scene the police department appoints one
of their best officers sachiko Yagami as
the case's lead investigator ironically
he is revealed to be light's father with
the assistance of Al the police continue
their investigation they examine the
overall timings of the deaths and
discover that they correspond to the
timetable of a college as a result they
conclude that Kira is a college student
who does not kill anyone during his
classes light who can easily hack into
the police database becomes aware of
this information and begins to change
his killing times when the police catch
wind of this they suspect that their
information is somehow being leaked to
Kira later as light is walking alongside
his new friend ryuk he realizes that an
unfamiliar individual is tailing him
ryuk reveals that the same person has
been telling him for two days hearing
this light is puzzled as to why ryuk
didn't alert him sooner and the latter
clarifies that he is neutral he supports
neither light nor the police the
statement scares light and he decides to
be more cautious from now on one day
light and his best friend shiori board a
bus and the unknown guy follows them
enraged he confronts the individual but
the person feigns ignorance a few
moments later a guy suddenly gets up
from his seat and takes the pass
passengers hostage it is revealed that
he is a wanted criminal who has just
escaped from prison light wants to help
but since he doesn't know the criminal's
name he simply writes on a piece of
paper that he is about to do something
when the unknown follower notices this
he attempts to stop light warning him of
the potential danger he also introduces
himself as an FBI agent named Rey
iwamatsu their conversation is cut short
the criminal approaches them and
snatches the piece of paper from Light
which is a torn portion of the Death
Note as soon as the criminal holds the
paper ryuk becomes visible to him the
sight of the frightening monster causes
the criminal to panic because of which
he runs out of the bus unfortunately he
is struck and killed by a fast-moving
vehicle meanwhile we get to know that
the FBI agent Rey had been tailing light
because the whole Police Department
suspects sachiko of divulging
information to his son now with Rey's
identity and appearance known to him
light aims to clear him from his way
however ryuk warns that he will be the
prime suspect if he does so to clear any
suspicion towards himself light decides
to collect the names of all the
undercover FBI agents connected to the
case for this he summons Rey to the
subway and communicates with him through
a transmitter light blackmails Rey into
inscribing the names of all the FBI
agents on a piece of paper threatening
to murder innocent passengers on the
train if he doesn't comply Rey has no
other alternative but to cooperate
subsequently he views the images of all
the agents in his database and light
inscribes their names on the Death Note
as a result all the FBI agents involved
in the case die out of chest pain as his
work gets done light heartlessly kills
Rey as well the latter's fiancee happens
to be on the same Railway platform and
when she notices Ray collapsing she
rushes to help him but it's too late
later at the police station lights dad
sachiko makes an announcement informing
the team that their lives are in danger
because Kira has begun killing
non-criminals as a result he allows team
members to withdraw from the case if
they are afraid being killed after
hearing this everyone except six
officers leave the room the six of them
demand that L reveal his true identity
before proceeding with the investigation
in the next scene they arrive at Elle's
apartment and learn that he is just a
young boy however he is extremely
intelligent which makes him stand out to
the rest of the officers L appears to
have deduced that Kira can manipulate
the cause of death so he advises the
team to use fake names to avoid being
targeted by Kira together they begin
working to capture the murderer as soon
as possible elsewhere Rey's fiancee
Naomi is devastated by Rey's death she
is revealed to be a former FBI agent who
previously worked for L she is now
determined to find her fiance's murderer
and exact Vengeance meanwhile L
discovers Rey's death video in which he
notices Rey pointing at someone just
before he dies thinking that he has
found the culprit he calls sachiko and
the team to inform them Al then shows
them photographs of the possible
suspects one of whom his light as a
result he wants sachiko's family to be
constantly monitored on the other hand
light starts scheduling deaths a week in
advance and tells ryuk that the mission
must continue even if something happens
to him the following day Naomi confronts
light with suspicion while he is at
College he recognizes her from the
railway platform but denies knowing
anything about Rey's death despite his
refusal Naomi suspects him and claims
that he is the one who used the bus Jack
to learn of Rey's identity realizing
that he has been exposed light quickly
writes her name on a piece of Death Note
but Naomi reveals that he can't kill her
because she gave him a false name before
leaving she vows to track down Kira and
will not stop until he is in prison
later that night light returns home and
notices an unusual smell which makes him
suspicious that someone has entered his
room without his knowledge he then
informs ryuk that his room has been
bugged with cameras and listening
devices his hunch turns out to be
correct as Alan the cops are constantly
watching him inside his room after
finding nothing fishy for the first few
days sachiko becomes assured that his
son is innocent however Ella insists on
continuing the surveillance because no
deaths have been reported while
monitoring light on the seventh day of
surveillance light is seen having dinner
with his family once he is done he
returns to his room locks the door and
unwraps a packet of chips munching on
them he studies pretending to be unaware
of the surveillance suddenly there is
news that a new criminal has been
apprehended and he dies soon after from
a heart attack when the agents learn of
this they declare that light is no
longer a suspect but L still has
suspicions however he orders his
assistant to remove all the cameras and
bugs from light's room unbeknownst to
them light had hidden the Death Note
inside the bag of chips and he covertly
wrote the criminal's name to free him
from the allegations one day shiori
calls light and proposes they meet at an
art gallery to which me happily agrees
during the call however he suspects
something is a mess because her voice
sounds strange in reality Naomi has
taken shiori hostage and is using her to
lure light to the meeting place in the
next scene after light arrives at the
art gallery he finds Naomi holding
shiori hostage she angrily demands that
he confessed to being Kira however light
denies the allegations and begs her to
release shiori in an attempt to make him
confess Naomi even reveals her real name
and asks him to kill her meanwhile Ellen
the team are watching the incident
unfold through CCTV cameras not long
after Naomi is distracted by police
sirens outside giving shiori a chance to
break free and run towards light but in
a state of panic she accidentally shoots
the poor girl as shiori slowly succumbs
to her injuries she kisses light and
confesses her love for him then she
passes away leaving him distraught soon
after the police arrive at the crime
scene and before they can apprehend
Naomi she commits the unthinkable the
scene then flashes back to a few hours
earlier where light learns of Naomi's
true name from her wedding card on his
note he then meticulously writes the
entire plot of Naomi's death at present
light is approached by his father who
apologizes for not saving shiori the
moment sachiko leaves the scene ryuk
arrives and asks if he ever expected to
lose her light turns around with an evil
grin revealing that he was the one who
actually plotted shiori's death with
Naomi he explains that he orchestrated
shiori's death as part of his plan to
make the authorities sympathize with him
and remove him as a suspect re-clicks
upon him with disgust in his eyes and
says that light is a demon and human
form just then Al shows up at the scene
holding the same bag of chips that light
used to write the names of the criminals
he introduces himself to light and
invites him to join their team to catch
Kira the movie ends as the two stare at
each other menacingly subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching